One further thin that I want to talk about is
do we disable assertions in production code?
For example, when we run the Python interpreter with the "-O" option,
which causes Python to enable some optimizations,
it disables assertions in order to make our code run faster.
The question we're asking here is is that a good thing?
It turns out that there are arguments we can make in both directions.
Let's first look at reasons why we might want to disable assertions.
One of the main advantages of disabling assertions
would be that it let's our code run faster.
Another advantage--and here we're starting to get into something,
which really depends on what we're trying to do with our system--
is that code running without assertions is less likely to stop running.
The code keeps going even after some sort of condition is found within the code
that would have triggered an assertion violation
if assertions had been enabled.
Here we really have to ask ourselves the question
what is it that we're trying to do with our system?
Is it better to keep going or is it better to stop?
Remember that keeping going after some condition is true
that will lead to an assertion violation may lead to a completely erroneous execution.
On the other hand, possibly, that's better than actually stopping.
Now let's move to disadvantages of disabling assertions in production code.
If our code happens to rely on some side effect performed by an assertion--
that is to say, if whoever wrote the code that we're using has violated
one of the rules for assertions that I gave you--
then turning off assertions is going to break the code.
Not only is it going to break the code, but it's going to break the code
in an extremely confusing way, because lacking assertions,
we're going to have a very hard time detecting the error
except that it's probably going to cause our system to crash in some confusing way
or just to do completely the wrong thing.
This is a real risk of turning off assertions in large systems.
The second reason is even in production code
it may be better to fail early rather than keep going.
Really, it just depends on what our system is doing.
The question is do our users want the system to die
or do they want the system to give them some completely wrong result?